my name is Raghav in common founders
company called treble ping we are
entirely focused on network services and
operators river systems developing
software for that for many many years
now we have the advantage that the
network services we use which are which
are doing different things and just IT
services they need to communicate to
each other on IBM cloud was the only
platform we can find these days where we
can deploy such horizontal services in
the cloud what it means for the consumer
is more speed faster downloads bigger
videos etc but this is not the challenge
for the carrier the challenge for a
carrier are other use cases like making
a car communicating to another car in
soup milliseconds to avoid an accident
and this needs totally different
deployment architecture errs and
topologies which cannot be solved by
just rolling in use of Farrelly's so we
need to create another infrastructure
for telco services which needs to go
into the field and it needs to be
distributed it's a cloud there's a
foundation for that so you don't need to
start to mound techo equipment in own
data centers anymore because 90% of the
spec is available in the cloud you can
book resources wherever you want to do
this is one of the huge advantages that
global carriers or the local carriers
can act globally but fulfilling the
local regulations and and because a
company from Germany can deploy in South
Korea which is one example we have done
on IBM cloud and deploying the service
last year in South Korea was about
talking to IBM engineers fixing some
networking problems for us and this
verse was a great experience it's not
just an API it's also an API with a
human which people helping you if is
really required just was great and made
the experience and we got a service
being
need
you